foreign
time to do another movie review
so I feel like I've maybe covered
um you know a great deal of obviously
American British uh Italian maybe some
Asian maybe some French horror movies uh
you know as on this series but I have to
say that one country's movies that I
feel like I've mostly neglected up to
this point is Spain
now Spain also had kind of something of
a horror boom in the 1970s like many
other countries did uh and in fact I
believe they're horrible horror boom was
largely kicked off by this classic film
that we're talking about today so I
figured it was time to like you know
give Spain some love because they made
some pretty cracking horror movies as
well
so 1972 uh he had a movie called tombs
of the blind dead I'm not even going to
attempt to pronounce the Spanish title
uh but the Spanish title roughly
translated to the Knight of blind Terror
so this movie was directed by Amando de
Osorio
and was successful enough to pretty much
almost immediately spawn three official
sequels uh you had Return of the blind
Dead uh in 1973 which I've also called
Return of the Evil Dead uh in 1974 he
had one called the ghost Galleon and
then in 1975 he had one called night of
the seagulls so those were like the
official uh sequels that were also
directed by Amanda de Osorio then you
also had kind of a handful of unofficial
sequels and spin-offs and like other
things that were like in Universe uh you
had one called La Cruz Del Diablo that
came out in 1975 and then Jess Franco
did Mansion of the Living Dead from 1982
which was sort of loosely based on the
lore uh more recently actually because
this is kind of a cult classic in 2009
there was actually like a really low
budget shot on video uh movie that was
called graveyard of the Dead that was
kind of like an unauthorized follow-up
and in 2021 there was actually two
movies that came out that were based on
the lore and like the monsters and stuff
from the original movie and this was
curse of the blind dead which was
directed by a guy named Rafael riccio
and then there was scream of the blind
Dead uh that was directed by Chris
Alexander so it's pretty easy to see
like how big of an impact this movie
like tombs of the blind Dead made like
back in the 70s in Spain and elsewhere
and I feel like now it's probably not as
well known it's obviously not very well
known like to mainstream culture but you
know horror aficionados you know
hardcore horror aficionados and like
like know it so it's kind of like a
minor cult classic I would consider it
another fun fact that I discovered when
I was researching this movie is that
when the movie was released in its
English language version uh and this is
pretty hilarious
the Distributors I'm assuming wanted to
cash in on that sweet sweet uh Planet of
the Apes money so because that was very
big at the time so they basically
re-edited tombs of the blind dead to
make it seem like it was happening after
the apocalypse and explaining I guess
like via narration or like a voiceover
or something that the villains of the
movie were actually intelligent Apes who
returned from the dead so uh no I'm not
making that up because I read that I'm
like you can't be serious
um yeah but this was actually an idea
that at least one person had and
presumably had a bunch of other people
go along with it which is you know
that's crazy to me uh the edited version
of the movie by the way uh is titled
Revenge from Planet Ape so no it doesn't
make sense to me either and if you've
actually seen this movie I just can't
imagine how it would be re-edited to
seem like it was after the apocalypse
but whatever
now considering that this movie was made
I feel like right around the time when
exploitation horror was just becoming
like a big thing
um and it clearly is targeting that
audience somewhat but I will say that
the movie is actually surprisingly
pretty light on Gore and nudity and
became even more light on Goran nudity
like after some countries particularly
like the UK and stuff like that trimmed
out a couple of the you know I guess
quote-unquote objectionable scenes that
it did have you know of which there
weren't very many
um but the tombs of the blind dead does
have this really kind of more Gothic
hammer-like atmosphere to it that kind
of goes a long way toward making it
memorable and I have to say that the
villains of the movie which are you know
a group of I guess you call them
revenants like Revenant Knights Templar
sort of
um who kind of return from the dead each
night to feed on the living and fuel
their immortality uh those villains are
awesome
and I kind of feel like the look of them
is probably the main reason to recommend
this movie to somebody that hasn't seen
it
um so the villains they're not quite
zombies and I kind of feel like Amanda
diasorio was like you know they're not
zombies it's not really the same thing I
mean technically they are because they
come back from the dead but you know
what I mean they don't it's not really
the same kind of zombie situation I
guess and they also have like a like a
vampire thing going on as well because
they feed on blood you know and they
kind of have some mummy style look it's
like a little bit in their look so I
mean whatever they are like whatever you
want to call them like I said I kind of
feel like they're revenants but whatever
it's a distinction without a difference
but they're definitely like their own
unique thing you didn't really see a lot
of stuff like this like officially in
the 70s um and they even ride horses
which I thought was kind of neat
although honestly I have no idea where
they keep getting the horses from like
every night like maybe they were buried
with the horses and the horse I'm like
are the horse is dead too I think about
this stuff way too much clearly now I
have to say though that as rad as this
movie is overall
um I found seen it before
you know a long time ago but then like I
watched it again like more recently
because it's on shutter
um I admit that I found it pretty slow
at times uh a lot of the character
motivations as well and kind of the
plotting are kind of muddled like I
think one of the biggest things that
bothered me was that like certain
backstories and character traits and
stuff are introduced but they don't
really like factor into the story all
that much going forward you're like well
what happened to that or what was that
all about you know what I mean
um but to be honest like the blind dead
themselves
are so cool and like so eerie looking
that you can pretty much almost forgive
like most of the movies other
shortcomings I feel like so the very
beginning of the movie you have like
this kind of ominous intro
um and it has like all of these shots of
the ruins that are gonna be like
factoring into the story somewhat and
there's like a really cool like very
Hammer like every Gothic score which was
really cool but then after that we're
kind of
you know there's kind of a neck breaking
like edit to you kind of get thrown onto
this pool deck in Lisbon Portugal with
all these vacationing people
um which is kind of a weird like
juxtaposition so on this pool deck we
meet one of our main characters whose
name is Betty and she happens to on this
pool deck run into her former like her
old best friend and former roommate I
guess uh whose name is Virginia
so Betty has actually recently moved to
Lisbon and she owns a mannequin Factory
which they took the pains to like bring
up and stuff and this I'm like oh that's
kind of neat and I wondered if that was
going to factor into the story but it
really doesn't and I was kind of like
kind of disappointed I was like oh maybe
it's gonna have like a little bit of a
tourist trap like kind of subtract
subplot to it but it doesn't really
factor in anything like I don't know it
should that's one of the things that I'm
talking about it's just like so specific
to say and you know take great pains to
say that this character like owns a
mannequin Factory and then like don't do
much of anything with that I think
there's like one more Scene like in the
mannequin Factory later on but it
doesn't really you know the fact that
it's a mannequin Factory isn't like
important to the plot or anything like
that so that's the kind of thing that
I'm talking about
so anyway
Virginia is on vacation with her friend
who I'm assuming is a friend with
benefits they don't really say that but
I was just like okay that's probably
what I thought it was but uh his name's
Roger and Roger uh very immediately
takes a very obvious shine to Betty
and invites her along on this excursion
that they're going on the next day now
Virginia seems upset by this and at
first I thought it was for the most
obvious reason because she actually even
though she's like oh me and Roger are
just friends or whatever but I thought
like she probably had more feelings for
Roger than she was letting on and so she
was getting jealous that you know Roger
was like suddenly fogging on Betty so
hard but you actually find out a bit
later
that it was actually Betty in Virginia
who had a thing going on like back in
college so Virginia is actually
presumably jealous because she wants
Betty all to herself not so much because
she gives a about Roger so I
thought that was kind of an interesting
twist
so I mean this whole
um relationship that they have back in
college it's kind of illustrated by this
very brief like very by today's
standards very very tame uh flashback of
the two of them like kissing and sort of
like making out like in their dorm room
like many years before but again this is
another thing that it seems like they
went a long way towards saying oh they
had a thing back in college and like you
know they're in love or whatever but it
doesn't really factor into anything
moving forward so I don't really know
why they took the trouble to like if it
wasn't going to play into the plot
further on but like I said that's
another thing it just seemed a little
disjointed but you know I I sound like
I'm being like negative and I'm not
because this is a cool movie but I'm
just saying that if I had been writing
it I probably would have made if you're
gonna introduce that like you know
factor into the story like a little bit
later on that's all I'm saying so anyway
because so they go on this excursion the
next day and because obviously there's
all this kind of simmering tension like
between the three of them
um you know on this train journey to
wherever the is that they're going
I don't actually remember if they even
said but uh so Virginia decides she is
gonna a nope out of the trip she asked
the train conductor if he'll stop and
he's like I can't stop there's a
station out here I'm not stopped in the
middle of nowhere that's like not
allowed and so she decides while her two
companions are not looking she basically
just like hops the off the train
she gets her and just like yeah I'm
out hops off the train and heads would
seems a little immature but whatever so
she gets like running off across this
field
um toward what appears to be like an old
village in the distance now like I said
it isn't clear what she was planning on
doing what she got there or how she was
expecting that she was gonna get home
but you know I mean since her doing this
is what gets her into the clutches of
the blind dead then we'll just roll with
it so the town that she finds out there
uh we kind of discover later on is this
abandoned medieval village type thing uh
called berzano and it's right on the
border between Spain and Portugal so
Legend has it that the Knights Templar
or at least like a fictionalized version
of the night's Templar they kind of like
uh stayed there back in like way back in
the day and they decided that they were
going to start worshiping Satan and like
sacrificing virgins in order to live
forever you know as one does now uh you
know to this day the locals claim the
knights actually like return from their
graves each night I guess like in order
to Feast on the blood of you know
whoever happens to be around I guess
whoever's like wandering around so uh
I'm actually not sure if the knights
even bother to like roll out of their
coffins if no one has been clueless
enough to like wander into their little
domain there on any particular night I
mean you know I'm thinking not like why
would they bother but you know what
really what the else have the dead
got to do so maybe they do I don't know
so when Virginia gets to this place uh
she pretty quickly Twigs onto the fact
that this place is you know empty of
people at least living people anyway and
she just kind of wanders around the
ruins for a while
and then for a pretty long while not
gonna lie
um and then she lights a fire and beds
down for the night because she's got
like all her camping
now no sooner has she fallen asleep
however then the blind Dead start you
know just crawling out the ground and uh
moving in on her you know perhaps
smelling some of that uh virgin blood
except I I don't think she's a virgin
you know what I mean I'm just that's
just my speculation on my part but I'm
just saying I mean she at least probably
had sex with Betty so that's that's
something right there and that was
another thing I wondered about too it's
like so the blind dead like crawl out
the graves and they're clearly like kind
of knocking over the
tombstones and like pushing aside the
stuff and I'm like do they put all the
back and like all the dirt back
because it looks all I don't know it's
supernatural I'm worrying about it too
much the reason that the revenants are
the blind dead is because way back in
the day they you know while they were
doing all the Satanism and sacrificing
Tom Fuller that they were doing
um they actually got caught by Church
authorities you know because you knew
that was gonna happen and they not only
got excommunicated but they also all got
hanged from trees and you know kind of
left there like as a warning to others
I'm assuming uh so crows pecked out
their eyes so now like their zombified
versions have to hunt by sound because
they don't have any eyes so I thought
that was like kind of a cool touch so
they all they just had these well I mean
their faces are kind of skulls so their
eyes are kind of sockets anyway but I'm
just saying that that's why they can't
see even though they can get up and like
walk around and stuff so the next
morning uh a very dead Virginia turns up
in the field which is adjoining Persona
like it's there's like a field there's
where the train track is because that's
where she jumped off and there's like
this big long film and then like you can
kind of see the brazano in the distance
so uh so they find her body the cops do
and she looks like she's been uh pretty
nibbled on uh gonna say now before her
death is public knowledge though like
before anybody knows about it like other
than the cops obviously Roger and Betty
actually go out to burzano themselves to
see if they can find Virginia because
they know where she hopped off the train
they saw her running off into the
distance they said well they're
presuming that's where she went so they
rent some horses and go out there
now during the course of their
investigation where they're kind of like
farting around and they find some some
of her stuff like her bedroll and all
that kind of stuff so they're like well
she was obviously here like where the
did she go but then they find out
later from the cops that she was
murdered so during the course of their
investigation uh they crossed paths with
this professor of some kind who tells
them the legend about the blind Ed like
all about the Knights Templar and all of
that and he also recommends to them that
they go and visit his scumbag son Pedro
like the professor's name is also Pedro
but I guess the son's name is Pedro too
so Pedro the Sun
is a Smuggler in the area where the
knights are supposedly active
um so they are going to go out there and
see if he knows anything about it now
Pedro as it happens is also Under
Suspicion for murdering Virginia because
of course the police don't believe that
there's like the zombified Knights
Templar like running around munching on
the townsfolk you know what I mean so uh
incidentally too this is another thing
that I'm talking about where they
introduce all of this stuff and then
they don't really do much with it
there's this whole bizarre kind of
subplot with Pedro and his wife
girlfriend lover whoever it is like her
name's Nina I think and so there's a
whole weird thing going on with them
and then the the weird thing going on
with them like sort of indirectly leads
to this scene which is really quite
unpleasant of Pedro raping Betty like
that happens so you know but again like
nothing really comes of that like it
seems like a big they spent a lot of
time on it and then like it doesn't
really factor into anything I mean other
than
Pedro like immediately getting attacked
and killed like by the knights after
that happens like almost like he's
getting comeuppance but the thing is
like the knights will just eat anybody
that wanders by because they just want
blood right so it's not so much that
they were punishing him so I just
thought that was really weird that this
character Pedro was introduced in like
all of and he's like he's he's like a
scumbag and a rapist and stuff but that
doesn't really factor into anything too
much so that's another thing like where
that I'm talking about you know so
meanwhile uh Virginia's corpse actually
gets up and starts killing people uh
starting with her first victim being
this weirdo morgue attendant who for
some reason likes to torment little
harmless frogs that are in this lab for
whatever reason so um so yeah so I guess
much like vampirism like I said uh
whatever it was that brought the blind
dead back from the dead you know um is
contagious like I said so if they bite
somebody and they die from it then
they'll get up and start walking around
too so I guess that's kind of like
zombies also so basically the rest of
the movie is just like the knights
riding around on the horses in actually
every time they show that it's actually
pretty cool because they do it's
completely silent like there's no score
and they do it in sort of like slow
motion so it looks like really you know
epic and and I think that they did
a really good job it's actually like
really effective
um you know so they do that and then
like occasionally eat one of the
characters whoever it is
um there's also one other flashback
scene in there
where uh that shows the nights like when
they were alive and they're sacrificing
a Woman by essentially like tying her to
like a torture rack you know stripping
her down to her undies and then riding
their horses around her in a circle like
they're inside but they're riding their
horses around her in a circle while
taking slices out of her like with their
sword so I guess it's kind of like a
ritualistic sort of thing
um even though it's obviously the most
inefficient sacrifice ever it's like hey
you just like take a knife and go dog
done you know what I mean but no they
have to like go around and take little
slices out of her so this is actually
the only scene in the movie that has any
significant Gore in it because there's a
couple of close-up shots of the swords
kind of slicing into the woman's flesh
like her torso and her tit and stuff
like that but I mean by modern standards
it's pretty much nothing I mean I don't
even think I would be all that bothered
about like a teenager like a kid seeing
it you know what I mean because it's
really not that big of a deal so as I
mentioned tombs of the blind dead I kind
of feel like it's really the atmosphere
of it and the villains themselves that
make this movie worthwhile because the
villains look so so cool like the blind
dead they're one of the coolest looking
like Monsters I feel like from that era
so I'm gonna say like if you like Hammer
movies like that kind of style and you
kind of want to see something that's
along similar lines as that but maybe
like with a more I don't know like
Continental Flair I guess if you want to
call it that then this movie might be up
your alley now I'm gonna say the run
time is not a long movie or anything
like that but it does seem like a little
bit padded with
you know characters sort of just like
wandering around way more slowly and
pointlessly than they need to like you
know when when Virginia first comes
across the ruins and it's just like
walking around looking at him like for a
long time so it's that kind of stuff you
could tell over there trying to make the
movie longer
um and as I mentioned there are like a
few interesting details that might have
made cool subplots had they been like
explored a little bit more like as like
I said like the mannequin Factory thing
like the prior relationship between
Betty and Virginia
um Pedro being like this douchebag
rapist that's never really gone into and
they need a great degree and also
whatever the deal was with that
morgue attendant because they did have a
couple scenes with the Morgans in it
where he's like poking at frogs and
stuff I'm like what the dude what's that
dude's deal you know what I mean like
and then he immediately gets killed so
it's just kind of like I kind of wish
that more they had explored like those
little interesting byways more you know
what I mean if you know if they were
gonna go to the trouble to introduce it
but you know on the whole
um it's actually not hard to see why
this movie became like I said kind of a
minor cult classic and ended up
inspiring essentially like an entire
series of official films and a bunch of
other media like both official and not
like I said there's been a bunch of
unofficial sequels or things that were
in universe or using the same monsters I
think there have been a couple graphic
novels too like using the same monsters
because like I said you can see how that
I mean it was original they weren't
quite vampires they weren't quite
mummies they weren't quite zombies
um you know what I mean but they had
their own look to them they kind of look
like grim reapers but kind of like all
up looking so it was like a
really cool lore and like mythology so
you can see why people like latched on
to that and wanted to use it in their
own work now as I mentioned I had seen
this movie a long time ago I think I
might even have it on DVD somewhere like
in the pile or up in the attic or
something because I have like a bunch
that I don't even know about that I
don't even remember but
um it's actually as of this recording
which is May 2023 at least in the United
States it's actually streaming on
shutter if you want to watch it I don't
remember if they have any of the sequels
on there I don't think I saw them but
you know I don't know I haven't actually
seen this sequels I don't think if I
have it's been so long that I don't
remember them but uh but yeah so like I
said if you like anything like that and
if you like Spanish horror from this era
then um you know by all means give it a
whirl if you haven't seen it because
it's actually like a pretty decent watch
so that will do it for this flickers of
fear and I'll see you guys again on the
next one bye